file this next story underneath the
criminal injustice system America's
criminal injustice system the son of a
police officer gets no time for 44
pounds of weed now to be sure I want to
state this upfront that I am very much
Pro legalization of marijuana even
recreational use I firmly believe it's
not even a statement of belief it's just
a fact that the what we allow in terms
of alcohol and the amount of damage and
carnage and what you know the
destruction of your body and not not to
mention you know lives that have been
taken because of alcohol compared to
marijuana you just you can't compare the
two and as well as the number of people
who are sitting in jail right now who
are still getting prosecuted and still
getting sentences jail time for both
marijuana possession as well as
marijuana sales and last but not least
when they attempted to smear both thumbs
on the twenty seven-year-old from Texas
who was killed by the white woman police
officer who claims as she thought she
was in he was in her apartment but she
was at the wrong apartment you remember
that story when they tried to smear his
name what did they say oh he had
marijuana in his apartment traces of
marijuana in his apartment there has
been such a long history of marijuana
being used to vilify people of color
specifically black people and so many
people black people specifically who are
sitting in jail because of the war on
drugs that the full decriminalization
and full legalization even for
recreational purposes is only the right
thing to do and for the benefit of every
community but specifically the black
community that being the case it's not
legal yet and there's still black people
and and and the Hispanic people and even
probably some poor some white people who
are still getting some jail time over
marijuana but not if you're the son of a
former police officer
Thomas Betts was 39 years old first of
all my dude year old what the hell are
you doing it 39 years old either I mean
you're you're either a kingpin and
there's something else going on me
forty-four pounds of marijuana suggests
that you have a really healthy
organization going on right or you're
breaking bad and you're gonna do with
the AMC way right you're trying to get
in break in what are you doing breaking
in to the weed game at 39 years old his
partner Michael Daly Michael Doorly 41
years old there's something more to the
story but let's set that aside
Thomas Betts is the son of a former
Miami Valley crime lab director Ken
Betts and this is what the article from
the my Dayton Daily News said they said
quote special prosecutor John Marshall
has asked the judge to honor the
presumption of prison which the judge
said was not necessary because of the
defendants lack of any serious criminal
record and there were no victims they
went on to say quote our job as
prosecutors is to make sure that
defendants are held accountable for
breaking the law said Butler County
Assistant Prosecutor John Marshall he
who was named as a special prosecutor to
avoid the appearance of conflict of
interest well considering that bets and
Doorley could have faced more than a
decade in prison about 11 years in
prison and they got off with five years
probation at the discretion of the judge
I don't think that you really
demonstrated that you got rid of the
conflict of interest I'm just I'm just
saying the conflict of interest doesn't
just go with the prosecuting attorney's
office it also rests inside of the judge
the the judge's chambers and so here we
are a guy who got caught with 44 pounds
of weed do you know how much weed that
is I mean seriously like I know guys
who've lost their entire families like
I'm laughing for not crying because I
know guys who have lost their entire
families
for having having a pipe with one one
pack it was packed one time with weed
like less than a less than and I come on
smaller than a nickel bag people have
been killed over one joint
they said they smelled weed own on
falando castile and so he the judge the
police officer who killed him literally
got off because the officer was scared
for his life because he smelled
marijuana and here this guy Thomas Betts
has 44 pounds of weed I didn't even
Google a street value of that someone
googled that and put it in the comment
section like this guy is a drug dealer
he is a major drug dealer and whereas I
absolutely support us decriminalizing
and legalizing the recreational use of
marijuana if you're still arresting
black people over little small trace
amounts of marijuana and here the son of
a police officer has gotten off 444
pounds of weed that that demonstrates
the problem in this country that has
existed for years I mean forever what's
coming to mind right now and I don't
have the specifics but it's coming back
to my mind as we speak was the campaign
against marijuana in the early 1900s
where where it insinuated that it made
black people crazy and and it made it
made white women fall in love with black
people and in this kind of Jim Crow -
styled vilification of black people or
mile around marijuana use and here we
are today having black people still be
arrested being killed by police officers
smeared because they had trace amounts
of weed in their apartment that they
were supposed to be in both Amin both of
Jean rather and a 39 year old either
drug lord or wannabe kingpin
I wanna be Heisenberg gets off with
probation for 44 pounds of weed now they
should take the weed and distribute it
to everyone so we can all have a great
afternoon no problem with the weed the
problem is with the criminal justice
system